[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le plateau
de la grande interview avec un invité
qui va sans doute vous surprendre didier
barbelivien bonjourbonjour auteur
compositeur interprète
vous êtes connu mais vos chansons le
sont peut-être encore beaucoup plus que
vous j'espère qu'on qu'on connaît plus
méchants sont deux chansons au compteur
mes chansons plus d'intérêt que moi
quand même plus de 2100 m2 de murs louis
alors je vais pas vous vieillir un parce
que c'est mon petit oui moi sommes nés à
l'époque du thé pas du mange disque et
huawei du terrain benoît autant qu
autant que je me souvienne j'ai toujours
vécu avec les chansons de de barbelivien
mais même moi voyez way à la naissance
non je plaisante quand ça a commencé
ça a commencé à mon avis parce que
je lisais beaucoup salut les copains
parce que d'innover le petit barbelivien
il faisait de droit non c'est le grand
barbelivien un moment qu'elle est la fac
de droit de la varenne-saint-hilaire
pour faire plaisir à ses parents mais
pour tous précisé non même pas pour le
resto u et la carte d'étudiant et la
dispense du service militaire c'était
très important ah bah oui j'étais
sursitaire ans et j'ai fait mes trois
jours j'avais 22 ans au fort de
vincennes enfin il est pas mais avec
l'idée je vais composer des musiques à
10 12 ans je savais que je ferai ça en
tout cas que j'essaierai de le faire si
si la musique ou du texte ou non en jeu
c'est bien simple je ne m'intéressais
cassard il fallait apprendre le solfège
à la j'ai tout appris chers amis tous
avec la théorie d'anheuser on arrive à
tous je vous conseille ça c'est un petit
bouquin enfin st oui c'est déjà assez
conséquent alors la première chanson
c'était pour qui la première chanson
balilla au non non non non d'adidas
teenstar nanan quand j'étais des buts
c'était pour un copain de lycée qui
s'appelait gérard stern hu est ce sa
façon le pseudonyme du rap permet pas du
tout c'était son nom c'était son nom et
je vais même vous apprendre un truc
c'est moi qui avais écrit la façade
c'est jean marc roberts qui avait écrit
la face b l'écrivain l'écrivain que
l'aveu que j'ai été élevé ouais ouais
mon copain alors moi vous
m'impressionnez
j'ai croisé plusieurs fois
avec le parcours qui est le vôtre vous
continuer de prendre des risques vous
aimez écrire ça marchait vous avez voulu
chanter en public ça marchait à marcher
ouais et maintenant vous voulez faire de
la radio j'en fais oui mais j'en ai fait
j'en faisais sporadiquement un petit peu
dans les années 80 ça m'arrivait je fais
de la télé aussi j'ai une émission qui
s'appelle db2 plus pur des joueurs pros
temps en temps sur france télévisions
non messieurs j'étais animateur à la
radio à la rentrée avec une idée
toute simple est dis moi qui tu écoutes
dans dis-moi qui tu chantes je te dirai
qui tu es oui dean et moi s'il est une
chose que tu changes ouais donc ce que
j'écoute ou heavy rain en avant avant de
chanter il faut écouter donc vous allez
interroger des personnalités diverses
sur leurs choix musicaux ouais pour ces
surprenants et ça c'est la diète
pickford alpes et exercices de
psychanalyse ouais enfin c'est docteur
freud du pauvre mais il ya un peu de ça
c'est à dire que je trouve que l'amour
des mots contenus qu'on peut avoir en
tant qu'auditeur en tant que wake public
en dit beaucoup sur nous les gens qui
aiment brassens sont pas les mêmes que
ce qu'aime brel pas les mêmes qui est
amené au ferret il pleuvait mais l'e3
mais pas de la même manière ceux qui
aiment vraiment un artiste précisément
ça traduit des personnages humains qui
sont différents alors c'est une émission
sur europe 1 vous le dimanche après midi
lorsque rémy très grande écoute à 15
hommes non mais moi qui connais rien à
ces sondages et à tout ça j'ai quand
même appris mon directeur des programmes
et m'a appris qu'on avait soixante mille
auditeurs
réseaux sociaux web ne font pas la pub
enfin les réseaux sociaux mouchin parce
que c'est donc
je suis à l'abri de ça mais non renelle
vous avez une page facebook
mais non mais non mais non vous êtes
cinglés j'ai une plage facebook parce
que ma maison de disques m'a dit qu'il
fallait un jour en avoir une alors on en
a une je dois parler trois fois dans
l'année sur la page facebook à part pour
annoncer mes émissions de tous les
dimanches twitter fait parce que c'est
vous qu'êtes vous avez d'autres en
magasin linkedin but non non c'est
encore moi je connais les penguins ça me
fait penser aux pâtes italiennes ouais
bon donc vous vous personnalité
vous vous en avez combien par semaine
une ou deux une une une vraie tous les
dimanches tous les dimanches et donc
voulais raconter en fonction de nom
c'est surtout alors guy savoy il était
là ya pas très longtemps m la sonde a ni
enfin c'était assez passionnant baggy
savoie c'est quelqu'un que je
connaissais dans la vie civile d'une
jeune cuisinier qu'un artiste pour un
chef étoilé
l'hôtel de la monnaie voilà ouais
j'essaie d'aider des cuisiniers enfin ma
j'ai beaucoup d'amis dit marc veyrat
eric france selon lui les coups de
poignard gagnaire lui l'aimé brassens
beau coin et surtout
le petit côté un peu frondeur de
brassens que brassens a toujours eu
brassens était à 10 plutôt évocateur un
anar de droite brassens avec eux tu me
dire je suis un anarchiste qui traverse
dans les clous et c'était vrai il ce
qu'il connaît bien dans la vie il avait
mal commencé et brassens dans la ville
il aurait pu être un peu comment dire
cambrioleurs il les a écrits d'ailleurs
sinon c'est un cambrioleur ni sur eux
sur un de ses disques et bien guy savoy
il s'est avéré être un peu plus
anticlérical qu'il n'imaginait away à
travers ses choix de chanson
j'ai eu
sophie davant qui est une grande
romantique
quoique attend toujours la révélation du
prince charmant le grand amour voilà
vous êtes bien au niveau de la règle et
les images arrivent vous êtes parfait
way qui j'ai eu j'ai eu michel onfray
c'est étonnant larhant michel onfray la
rencontre avec michel onfray parce que
moi j'aime beaucoup michel onfray c'est
à dire les interviews que je voyais de
lui me le rendait attrayant mais je
l'avais jamais rencontré sa fille je la
connais alain souchon ça c'est des gens
que je connais mais quand c'est
quelqu'un que j'ai jamais vue de ma vie
c'est assez étonnant là aujourd'hui je
vais catherine mais non non non
c'est la semaine prochaine je vais faire
qu'attribuer je sais pas quand elle ne
sera pas diffusée politique elle a des
choix et banier je suis athée
catherine nay c'est la générale c'est
une amie personnelle dans la vie mais je
ne sais pas ce qu'elle aime elle même
bien moi voyez mes ailes et elle est
pudique toujours à bien j'aime beaucoup
tes chansons alors de temps en temps
même en cite une ou deux comme ça mais
elle a des goûts a elle aussi que je
connais pas ce qui est vachement sympa
c'est d'arriver avec
ce qu'elle aura choisi vous parlez de
barbara vous parlez
oui sûrement mais barbara pour l'instant
le comment le turnover des artistes
c'est beaucoup brassens et barbara mais
les deux b mais j'attendrai fait des
frayeurs hauteur de leurs chansons
compositeur c'est des chanteurs que vous
n'avez pas servi
bt non pas du combat qui a pas du tout
alors là je suis admiratif non non
seulement ça m'embête pas ce sont des
gens qui m'ont appris qu'ils m'ont formé
moi je suis un parce que dans jacques
reiller mes disques de barbara quand
j'étais jeune à force d écouter oui
parce que dans votre métier avec deux
catégories de oui il ya les interprètes
voilà les interprètes y ait besoin
d'auteurs ou exprimer ce qu'il ressent
basse et ils sont formidables puis sedan
en temps ils ont besoin de moi oui voilà
on va pas leur jeter la pierre et il ya
des gens qui font auteur compositeur
interprète il y en a qui feraient mieux
de faire qu'interprète vous voyez non
non mais les les auteurs compositeurs
enfin la génération d'avant que moi j'ai
admiré franchement étaient des génies dg
alors on va en parler on va rester là
sur dis-moi ce que tu chantes discuter
les hommes politiques vous allez les
interviewés quand même
j'aimerais mais là on va rentrer en
période électorale de la droite non j'ai
pas le droit il ya des hommes politiques
du coni fier aux bains j'en connais un
paquet ouais ouais ouais donc vous
parler chansons
ben ouais macron vous l'avez rencontré
n'ont jamais j'ai écrit une chanson il
concerne s'appelle le maître des
horloges oui j'ai entendu parler de
famille oui nicolas sarkozy abbott et le
kop bah oui c'est plus qu'un papier ce
qu'ils chantent les c'est comme
quelqu'un de ma famille et chante de
tous de tous deux des chansons de moi de
sardou dessous sont le forestier de
cabrel de tout donc et lorsque ça dit
quoi ça raconte quoi les chansons qu'ils
rabat il aime énormément
comment dire
d il aime énormément les créateurs quoi
c'est quelqu'un qui qui aiment les
chansons qui racontent quoi oui il est
très sensible aux homos enfin je veux
dire il est pas
il n'est pas l'époux de carla bruni
impunément carla bruni c'est un grand
auteur français quand même on oublie
souvent de le dire parce que il ya des
il ya des filles c'est souvent chez les
filles la plastique cash le reste
véronique sanson
c'est une grande auteure compositeur je
n'arrive pas à dire aux tris
compositrice mais
c'est un grand auteur compositeur
français pour moi oui c'est hors genre
voyez le mot d'auteur compositeur ce
comme éditeur et les mains pour moi
ecrivaine scellait quoi enfin pour
gagner un proverbe qui dit là la musique
adoucit les moeurs fait vrai ou pas oui
si je pense que c'est les hommes
politiques qui chante et qui bat ils ont
tous les temps héroïques sympathiques
ils sont pas forcément mauvais mais
chiant mais non mais laisse passer c'est
vraiment il n'ya pas d'hommes politiques
méchant faut faut rester calme y'en a
pas non à part les gens qui jouent mais
gens qui peuvent même avoir un caractère
un peu plus comment dire trempé ouais
trempé emballé que d'autres mais je ne
connais pas de gens foncièrement méchant
en france on en a pas pour moi des
méchants méchants
on m'avait dit mais c'est pas à trahir
un secret nicolas sarkozy que vous
connaissez quand même vous êtes sans
doute un de ceux qui le connaissaient le
mieux dans paris il est il est mieux
maintenant que lorsqu'il était président
ben il est mieux maintenant
de mon point de vue personnel et moi qui
le fréquente
régulièrement ce que je vous dise et
c'est vraiment comme quelqu'un de ma
famille je trouve que c'est maintenant
qu'ils devraient être président hu est
absolument parce qu'il a une sagesse
aujourd'hui un recul l'intelligence il
l'est toujours eu un donc on va pas il a
très envie
je sais pas je dire
il faut jamais regretter les choses ou
le dessin et nous fait ce que nous
sommes
mais moi quelquefois je me fais la
réflexion je dis à ma femme j'ai eu tu
vois c'est maintenant que nicolas
devrait être présent c'est comme ça il
est bien de sortir un livre ouais un peu
sa collection
son jardin se querellent en matière
culturelle n'y a pas de musique
non mais non par la vie pex il ya des
métallos il ya eu quatre noms mais
dedans il parle de nous parle de moi un
peu le restiez de julien clerc ou et ses
goûts calogero des gens qui aiment bien
il aimait bien johnny hallyday beaucoup
mais beaucoup
pour chialer sardou when she vous a
écrit pour johnny hallyday ricardo nous
a écrit pour tous ces gens là bah oui
j'ai vu j'ai eu ce privilège moi je
considère que c'est un privilège jouer
bon ça raconte beaucoup de choses sur
les hommes sur les gens sur leur
caractère mais ça raconte aussi beaucoup
de choses sur la société dans laquelle
nous vivons parce que la chanson c'est
le reflet de la société alors je vous
pose pas la question maintenant on
s'arrête 30 secondes et puis on reprend
revers
[Musique]
aller retour sur le plateau de la grande
interview avec didier barbelivien il est
beau ce jingle il faut qu'on en parle
c'est du boulez c'est du bel à bartok il
faut absolument que je me renseigne pour
vous répondre à ses passions moi j'ai un
générique sublet sur l'année on va me
dire dans l'oreillette et à ce moment là
je vous le dirai en plateau prenez aubry
moi voilà bon on veut enfin ouvrir les
paris et puis on va auteur compositeur
c'est pour ça qu'ils s'intéressent à la
musique finalement barbelivien 2000
chansons au compteur c'est ce qu'on
disait c'était beau jeu un catalogue est
pas mal quand même bon ça va bravo
patrimoine je pense oui mais surtout
j'ai fait des bons souvenirs c'était
heureux de décrire ses chances alors
vous avez écrit pour toutes les grandes
vedettes
et puis des inconnus sont alors
peut-être question devenue vedette grâce
aux chansons que vous avez écrit c'est
arrivé est arrivé à johnny hallyday ah
non lui il était là quand j'ai fait pour
lui non mais ce qui me ce qui me frappe
c'est que sans doute les chansons
reflètent un peu de la société dans
laquelle on vit vous vous avez à moi je
l'avais commencé à travailler dans les
années 60-70 début 70 souris et elle est
la vie facile non non je sais pas si tu
étais allé trente glorieuses ouais je
sais pas si la vie est facile mais notre
optimisme était était au taquet on peut
dire on trouvait la vie
dont
notre jeunesse je n'y ai dit mitchell
plus louis michel a fallu les copains
j'étais tout à fait pas moins celle un
peu la presse sa bulle et connaître
parce que celle ci s'était surtout les
années 60 mais moi c'est ce qui me
commencer ce qui me captive est dans ces
années là c'est à dire j'étais un
écolier un lycéen un peu moyen mais par
contre j'étais licencié en salut les
copains chanson française et tous ces
chiens battable alors là vous avez fait
dalida on voit là j'ai écrit pour dali
aussi vous avez fabriqué des tubes non
j'ai vu des tubes c'est à dire des
chansons à succès où elle invite moi je
me suis jamais répond c'est un départ
comme on fait une chanson à succès non
je me suis jamais vu comme un fabricant
je suis un traducteur mois de ce qu'ils
sont
par exemple dalida je la connaissais
depuis que j'étais petit cop elle
chantait bambino on est quand elle
chantait bambino j'avais l'impression
qu'elle me parlait à moi
donc quand j'ai connu dalida je me suis
dit maintenant je vais lui parler à elle
donc j'écrivais des chansons
qui lui correspondait je pense et je
faisais la même chose avec sylvie vartan
faut jamais oublier que j'ai acheté
petit tout les disques et les chansons
de ces gens là j'achetais leurs disques
donc quand j'ai eu à écrire pour eux
j'étais déjà
comment dire comme à la maison un peu
oui ça l'est je l'inventé complet
franchement vous avez vous lui avez fait
des chansons très fort qui lui
correspondent ouais avec françois berne
m on était 2 c'est en effet une vedette
sinon parce qu'elle est très connu à
l'efs
a beaucoup fait sur trois albums on a
beaucoup
comment dire porter patricia kaas on
peut donc faire vous voulez dire que
vous la connaissiez bien non pas du tout
je vais connaissez absolument la grippe
à renforcer non et quand elle a
enregistré mademoiselle chante le blues
je ne l'avais jamais vu jamais
et vous l'aviez pas forcément fait la
chanson pour elle mais elle est pas du
tout fait pour elle alors non mais
attendez moi j'ai deux factions d'écrire
il ya les chansons que je destine à des
requins prennent ce commande ou vous
disposez à mieux johnny vous l'avez fait
ça peut marcher pas du tout ça peut
marcher et ça peut ne pas marcher et il
ya des chansons que j'écris comme ça
et les artistes passent au studio et
font leur marché voyez comme quelqu'un
qu'il présenterait une collection plaît
pas voir pas exactement pareil et
vêtements des fringues moi je dis geste
a fait comme chanson jeudi j'ai ça ça ça
et ça
voilà si vous voulez y compris qu'en gt
gt jones la mousse des djeuns est
fatigué ayez des yeux cernés avec johnny
on se couche et verts avait connu il
compris avec sardou c'est pareil non je
fais des chansons non non non on écrit
avec michel on est on a toujours écrit
de manière
très proche bien que n'ayant jamais
écrit face à face on écrivait des
chansons on s'envoyait des des fax au
dévouement des extraits c'est comme ça
que vous aviez travaillé
il ya des choses qui me fascine et c'est
peut-être ma formation d'économiste vous
fait poser cette question c'est que en
fait si ses chansons six chanteurs il ya
là il ya les grosses vedettes de la
chanson elle passe les générations elles
suivent leur ire elle passait elle passe
elle passe encore pas bon ça veut dire
qu'elles s'adaptent à l'air du temps
est ce que ça veut dire que l'intuition
oui et là où est ce que il ya du
marketing dans tout ce nom il jauge il
ya deux noms hier johnny hallyday y
avait du marketing mais vous pouvez le
dit non non il ya eu comment dire l'envi
en fâcher jody fin des années 60 début
effectivement il chantait bonnie and
clyde après il est un hippie à prêter 1
mais c'était la mode musical de l'époque
qui voulait ça c'est à dire tout d'un
coup on était traversé par des courants
musicaux oui où tout le monde disait ah
mince c'est vrai que c'est bien les
guitares sèches le flower power alors
que quatre ans avant c'était les
guitares électriques
dehors à tout acte de vapeur non je
pense que
on a tous été tributaire de l'air du
temps
aujourd'hui c'est le rap c'est
non il ya eu 10 qu il regarde et comment
michel sardou est resté collé à
l'actualité mais autant tout faire
maintenant pour charles aznavour aussi
aznavour au 6 mai mais comment dire ils
suivent ya pas d'actualité les lancers
au regard des risques
inhérents de l'info il regardait tout
bas pas du tout dallas est submergé des
études sociologiques derrière ce cap
après coup quand sardou chante les
villes de grande solitude
c'est une chanson pour lui ce un décor
ce n'est pas encore le malaise des
banlieues c'est pas vrai c'est pas léger
région encore pas du tout non quand il
chante le france il est choqué par le
ton va démanteler le france mais il
n'est pas comment dire quand il chante
j'habite en france on ne peut pas dire
où ils habitent en france à l'époque
comme 50 millions de français basé à nos
d'événements sauf qu'il le dit c'est
comme ça et ça résonne dans l'opinion
publique
je pense qu'un artiste je pense qu'un
artiste et est fait pour ça il est là
pour raisonner de manière comment dire
si c'est pas un sujet entre guillemets
sociétal il peut l'être de manière
sentimentale proche du public jacques
brel exprimaient des sentiments très
personnel où léo ferré qui se
retrouvaient
correspondre aux goûts et aux réactions
sentiments du public et les politiques
la chanson
elle à l épaule il paraît que oui pour
moi non jeudi paris quick avait t
on peut pas dire sanaa mais j'aime bien
catalogué comme un intellectuel de luz
dont il y avait un prof de français qui
étaient de gauche pendant toute ma
jeunesse et qui me disait toujours
barbelivien mettez vous bien ça dans la
tête tous les politiques toutes les
folies et
c'est vrai que ça correspondait à l'idée
du marxisme
léninisme si c'était pas fou et ça l'est
toujours c'est pour moi ça garde
toujours un un parfum de vérité il s'est
simplement agi que moi ça me concernait
pas dans la chanson ça
je me voyais pas
être un auteur ce qu'on appelle entre
guillemets j'ai engagé mais ce qui est
drôle c'est que les auteurs de enfin
l'auteur de ma jeunesse celui dont on a
fait
un chanteur engagé toute sa vie ne
l'était pas qu'il s'appelait bob dylan
ou outre atlantique et on a toujours
voulu nous vendre bob dylan comme un mec
engagé et dylan de son propre aveu
disait mais non pas du tout je peux je
collectais les idées mes chansons à la
bibliothèque comme une cible c'est vrai
quand même pour nombre de chanteurs
notamment en france jean ferrat était
engagée par l'union bien sûr mais il
était j'ai toujours dit jean ferrat
était plus engagés politiquement que
politiquement pour moi bien sûr il était
proche du parti communiste les ailes à
mon dieu il n'y a pas de honte des
communistes mais quand on en a tous les
trucs que j'entends quelquefois aux
cantons le resort staline et tout serait
c'est un supporter aujourd'hui là quand
vous écoutez ce qui fait que quand ce
que vous faites est ce que vous avez
comment vous jugez la société française
est ce que la chanson est ce que est ce
que la chanson reflète son état est ce
que leur a par exemple un peu oui le oui
oui je pense que oui le rap à corps à
corps et sa paille votre pass de thé le
rap mais ce n'est ni ma tasse de thé
nîmes on commence bien
ni quelque chose qui me
donc je crois donc ça me choque
absolument pas mais vous savez dans
l'expression de l'amour avec des preuves
péri contre le rap ouais mais dans
l'expression créatrice créatrice veut
dire charles y avait peut-être été
énervé par le rap mais si on écoute les
chansons qui faisait avec pierre roche
dans les années mais juste avant guerre
est juste après il était très moderniste
il était très comment dire
il ya d'écrit il ya de la création dans
le rap il faut pas prendre un mec je
pense à un type bon vous allez me dire
vous vous citer tout le temps les
américains mais djezzy et c'est un vrai
créateur skipper faut écouter faut
écouter ses ambiances musicales il faut
mais il y en a il y en a autant en
france d'aider des gens qui d'abord le
métier drapper voyez quand vous êtes sur
scène que vous tenez une salle à une
foule pendant deux heures en débitant
ces mots là mes chers amis ne savent pas
des fois c'est une énorme performance
une mémoire un machin sens du rythme et
du rite du placement des mots et mallory
derrière il n'y a pas de grandeurs pour
un rappeur et voyez faut envoyer est-ce
que la pandémie est la période que nous
vivons aujourd'hui a engendré une
création particulière de la part d'un
auteur compositeur comme vous par
exemple si vous en avez profité pour
dire bon bah je met au piano je vais
travailler ou à la guitare non non non
la pandémie je suis un peu comme la et
pourquoi un peu d'enjeu croisette comme
la majorité des français ça a été
quelque chose de
et c'est toujours quelque chose d'un
handicap pour moi tu pars années de l'an
paralysant ses os et c c'est anxiogène
c'est c'est tout ce que vous voulez
c'est bah c'est pas fait pour au pot
pour les êtres humains ni pour les
animaux doivent faire preuve quand même
une mutation
ça provoque juste consent maire de plus
que de raison et que et qu'on est
comment dire un peu écrasée par ce à
quoi je trouve angoisses et parfois à
quai ouais angoisses et non inquiet je
ne sais pas montserrat trop c'est à dire
que bref si on veut être raisonnable
à l'échelle de la planète c'est pas
grand chose mais quand vous apprenez que
c'est votre copain ou votre voisin ou
quelqu'un de la famille qui a été frappé
par cette maladie par cette épidémie
forcément c'est dramatique c'est pour ça
que moi je milite pas je milite pas
militer mais quand on me pose là le truc
de le 2 de l'opposition aux vaccins ce
sa profonde je me dis mais c'est pas
possible les gens soient si bête jeudi
évidemment qu'il faut c'est faire un
séminaire faire confiance aux médecins
mais c'est pas tellement c'est même pas
de faire confiance aux médecins c'est en
nous vaccine depuis qu'on est né j'ai
jamais vu un vaccin s'attaquer à la
population mais j'ai vu des maladies oui
décimé une partie de la population je
veux pas reparlé du sida mais mes
enfants le sida en a tué plus qu'à son
tour
si demain et les traitements grâce à
dieu qu'on a trouvée pour enrayer le
sida un peu je dis bien les traitements
ya pas eu de vaccins mais s'il y avait
un vaccin contre le sida dans les années
80 mais on
on aurait pris des pharmacies d'assaut
si je reviens à votre métier pour
terminer parce qu'il faut qu'on termine
mais tron les trois meilleures chansons
pour vous c'est impossible c'est ainsi
je suis
très très respectueux et très admiratif
du choix de mes invités parce que je
leur en impose 5 et si je devais faire
ma propre vie je vous dis ça que je
voulais je serai bien ennuyé terminer
comme ça mais je serai très ennuyé de
choisir mes cinq chansons comme j'ai dit
à certains interprètes vous pouvez
revenir plusieurs fois ouais bon ben
vous viendrez une fois
merci beaucoup l'émission est terminée
didier barbelivien je vais vous laisser
à vos auteurs à votre piano à vos
guitares à la scène aussi parce que vous
allez on boucle ce bien de santé bientôt
vous retrouvez cette émission en replay
sur la chaîne bien sûr mais vous la
retrouvez aussi sur les réseaux sociaux
et sur le site internet arte france
point tv merci beaucoup mais merci
d'avoir les hebdos
[Musique]